alors en fonction des théo était bas je
vais te faire une interview à bendaoud
tpr est la plus grande joie de ta
carrière
la plus grande joie de ma carrière
lorsque j'ai eu un gala d'annuler que je
suis rentrée à 8 heures le régulateur
dans la chambre d'hôtel merdique et la
plus grande déception c'est d'essayer de
se masturber que les pieds nickelés n'y
arrive pas c'est dur cela prend du temps
effrayant le plus grand moment de ta vie
c'est maintenant
le pire moment de ta musique médias
parce que tu dis ça va être prêt
et chez françoise alors oui ce que tu
préfères chez françoise rien
non c'est un tout je veux avant tout ce
que tu détestes france passe
ses côtés paperasse un peu un pari
comptable que moi que des capricornes
quoi
je ne rentrerai pas dans l'avant
moi qui croyais qu'on avait parlé
d'astrologie bon mais vous pouvez lui il
est phrase que tu dis comme ça des fois
j'aimerais bien
savoir ce que tu en penses tu des
phrases définitives et tragique tu dis
entre guillemets j'aimerais tellement
avoir envie de quelque chose c'est à
dire quoi que le matin tu te lèves et tu
as envie de rien mais il sait déjà déjà
j'ai envie de me lever c'est déjà pas
mal beaucoup de gens résident en ville
et pas me l'enlever mais il faut que
j'aille faire ceci ce nom je me lève et
c'est ça qui est terrible c'est que moi
je je tourne tu vois où cinéma bien sûr
et puis par moment d'accord tu aimes
bien tu aimes bien
comme tu sais pas très bien ce que tu as
tu dis par exemple j'aime bien avoir mal
aux dents est ce qu'au moins tu sais où
tu as mal
c'est bizarre quand même non
ah ouais mais ça sent ont rejoint d'un
état
un état où tout va pas très bien et
c'est insidieux c'est sournois on ne
sait pas exactement edel ou parfois on a
mal à la dent dit tiens je sais que j'ai
mal je sais où j'ai mal là tu es content
c'est pas mal mais je vais ravis chez le
dentiste
j'avais l'air bizarre je sais quoi faire
ce jour-là -
étudient aussi la vie sur ces fronts des
aphorismes la vie c'est faire semblant
ne pas être mort c'est-à-dire coeff rien
avant
ton canular le plus réussi
qu'à l'époque vous remettez les
chaussures aux
côtés des portes ça pourrait faire
nettoyer j'en voyais mon secrétaire
acheter les mêmes alors soit une taille
en dessous
le butin c'était génial parce que les
mecs trouvait toujours une explication
ça doit être le chauffage par le sol aps
m
les pieds c'est pourquoi ça me faisait
il y en a eu d'autres ont chié tous dans
un journal bon il vous foutez le feu au
journal et ont tapé à la porte on disait
au feu et bien entendu la personne
devait dormir donc son premier réflexe
était d'arriver pieds nus ou en pyjama
et 2
et de taper les fiables les pointures de
ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus